Johnny Manziel Heisman Trophy winner
former NFL player played in the CFL and
then had a little bit of time in the
Alliance of American football but now
that League has disbanded and Johnny
joins us now good morning Johnny how are
you good morning my friend how are you I
actually I actually go by John these
days so you know I'm just kind of
turning over the page forward a little
bit okay is this breaking news that
Johnny Manziel is no you're the artist
formerly known as Johnny Manziel all
right so you're all grown up I guess
John Manziel joining us on the program
what's your future what's your football
future right now um right now obviously
with you know the news coming out last
week and you know walking out to the
practice field and expecting to go
through another day on the field and
seeing how quickly the AF just kind of
you know evaporated it caught me as a
surprise a little bit because I was
having so much fun in Memphis probably
more fun than I've had you know our last
game at Texas A&M versus my plan moving
forward is in wake up every day with
with you know to get back on the field
to continue working on my craft and
whether that's you know working in San
Diego George Whitefield and continuing
to try and get back to what I feel like
I was you know a little bit of a surgeon
with the football in my hands and you
know I feel good and I'm gonna continue
to keep my head down and just keep
working on you know what matters the
most to me and that's football how did
you find out that the AAF was disbanding
you know we're addressing practice and
you know pretty much you know take your
pads off and and head back to the
beating room and you know for the second
we walked into the meeting room was a
pretty you know different vibe than we
normally get from walking into the
building and you know coach Singletary
set us down you know kept a pretty
riffle with us and what was going on it
still holds the day's often they were
keep us posted as the day went from day
one are you the greatest quarterback in
Memphis express history I don't think so
no Brandon it's overs or what he did and
this time he was there was okay you're
one of the top two okay I like I like
Christian Hackenberg a lot but no no no
no no no no no you were you were better
than Christian Hackenberg did you keep
your Jersey of course I did
are you gonna frame in I'm taking a
couple pit stops here taking a couple
pit stops so far so I'm trying to you
know keep the memories have you heard
from an NFL team that'll allow you to
try out you know I've kind of left a lot
of it up to my agent I've had times in
the past over the past two years where
you know I had people talking to me and
you get some interviews you sit down and
talk with some people and it's really
easy to get your hopes up and get
flowing with what's going on the people
that are talking to you but you know
right now I have open communication with
some coaches in the league and you know
I'm trying not to you know get too up
about it or anything that kind of comes
my way so I'm just taking a day-by-day
and tried it you know you know make the
best of what's going on click clear the
assembly why are you not in the CFL I
think looking back in my time going to
Canada I was so hungry to get back on
the field and play that I took the first
opportunity I did to get back on the
field and when I looked up at things a
year later they they weren't exactly
what they were when I originally signed
in Hamilton would you don't where I
thought I was going to be learning the
run-and-shoot watching Colt Brennan
highlight taste to learn the offense
from you know the Hawaii so you know I
have no regrets about going to Canada
and you know it's just one of those
chapters in my life that you know now
I've closed the book on and looking
forward to better things moving forward
your decision or their decision you know
I don't really
going into a ton of detail everything to
happen but looking back at it now
I'm happy you know Memphis was exactly
what I needed in my life from this first
day I walked you know on the practice
field and got to see eleven guys on the
field
things were slow for me again and it was
a great chance for me you know I've been
in a tell sitting where high bullets and
it is chaos with the kind of pass
rushers that are in the NFL it was it
was perfect for me and I had no regrets
but he's John Manziel former Heisman
Trophy winner joining us Dan Patrick
show yeah you have to be looking at the
NFL landscape with quarterbacks and you
see Baker Mayfield and you see Kyler
Murray coming in I mean there's they're
similar styles to what you made famous
there how do you feel the where where is
the game right now in the NFL as far as
the quarterback play I think you know
obviously with what I believe you know
is gonna happen what Kyler moving
forward and obviously with Baker going
number one last year
you know the stigma of having to be
six-four six-five and you know be
prototypical for what the NFL was before
in the past I think that's kind of out
the window and I think with how creative
these coaches are in the NFL if you get
yourself into the right setting that you
can absolutely have success so I think
it's trending to finally
can you play ball or can you not play
and if you can somebody who believes in
you and says you know we're gonna tailor
some of these things around you to be
successful I think that's the recipe for
success not that you know you're just
undersized or you you know dual-threat
or whatever you know get into a
situation where somebody believes in you
and trust you enough to put plays in
that fit your style of play this
surprises people when I tell them that
it takes a certain mental makeup certain
players certain personality to be a
backup quarterback in the NFL because
everybody wants to start everybody has
an ego everybody was successful at a you
know previous stop in college and high
school could you be a backup quarterback
knowing your competitive personality
I could be a practice swag quarterback
with with my competitiveness and I say
that because this reason no you're as
good in the NFL as you are prepared for
it you know I learned that the hard way
my first year in Glee weren't just
mental sharpness and against your
opponent week in and week out and really
you know you look at the best they know
what they're doing before the defense
even does it just based on the front or
off a look and you know when you're not
prepared for it you can get in a little
bit over your head with with guys you
know what everywhere and the pass
rushers that are in the NFL so you know
I'm as competitive and anything any
sport any game any little thing as
anybody that out of that but all I want
is you know an opportunity to come in
and you know prove that I believe I'm a
different person these days I believe
that you know I'm going to put in the
work to get to where I want to be and
I'm not so scared of that anymore if you
can't play football if that doesn't
happen
could you be a football analyst would
you want to do that I want to do
anything moving forward
what's the world preferably football but
I've been watching this you know Final
Four this you know NCAA tournament for
the last week and I I feel like I would
be successful at anything in sports you
know I'm keeping it one day at a time
but you know at the end of the day I
feel I have a great passion for the game
of football again after being in Memphis
seeing the game learning it and being
able to you know just help behind in the
quarter of my position based off my
experience so you know down the road I
would love to you know ideally if you
know the NFL does it call and I could
see myself being in a coaching setting
or you know work my way up and doing
something like that I joy you know
coaching and helping younger people to
get to a level that they want to be so I
absolutely see anything whether it's
media side or whether it's Noah coaching
saw in my plans if for whatever reason
you know what I truly want and getting
back to the NFL doesn't transpire
can you teach your style
don't think you know I've gone back in
the last week and watched almost every
single game from 2012 and 2013 SEC my
time at A&M and there were some things I
look back on and kind of just shake my
head you know how they played out so now
there's things above all that come
natural and you watch guys that'll be
small but you know I don't think you're
ever going to get a carbon copy of it
again but the thing I can't do and can't
help you with is give you tools that
I've learned from guys like Varian Jakes
Kyle Shanahan and the people that I was
around and you know my career so I feel
like I can prepare somebody to help them
go out and slow aim back just play ball
not have to think I heard you had a
movie question for me how can I help you
movies are mine it's not much of a
question it's just your cameo on the
Waterboys is top notch and I've been
watching I'm a big island sailor guy so
I'm continuously since I've been on the
show for the last year continue to see
you pop up and some of the movies that
I've been watching so just but I just
want to say it's been it's been
enjoyable
I'm an actor John and I'm glad that you
noticed that you got a great eye and I
think you just proved it it's like
hitting the hot Rossio I'm Mike Evans
you know when it comes to you finding me
this is security blanket in the acting
well I love it have you been in any
movies I don't believe so I've been in a
couple commercials but how did it jump -
to the movie screen alright let me see
if I can put in a good word for you with
Sandler would love nothing more I have
to kill more water boy - favorite movies
of all time hands down
John good luck and hopefully you get an
opportunity and please stay in touch and
if you need a place for that AAF Jersey
- hang I'm moving into a new man cave
it'd be kind of nice to have some a
you're the first aaf player and the only
one that I've asked for their jersey so
just considered that I can do you one
better it'll be on the way this week
they're grass stain on there I mean it's
it game you and I mean I don't want to
be too particular I mean Jared golf said
about 15 plays hey good luck and stay in
touch we appreciate it absolutely always
a pleasure have some fun that's John
Manziel no longer Johnny Manziel who
knew I never knew that if you missed any
of these celebrity interviews this week
from the mercedes-amg man cave go to the
Dan Patrick show app where you can watch
and listen from inside the mercedes-amg
mancave mercedes-amg driving performed
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]